[Music]
whoa I just got invited to give the
commencement address at Harvard this
year that's amazing
I remember you did it 10 years ago when
Priscilla graduated I was there yeah it
was a lot of fun uh you know 30 years
later than I was supposed to but uh I
enjoyed it they know we didn't actually
graduate right oh that is the best part
they actually give you a degree you
don't even have to go to class no no you
just put that degree on your resume and
it looks great can you help me figure
out what I'm going to say yeah we should
work on it together let's go get some
more snacks all right so you get to wear
the hat and everything oh you
bet I got to be honest with you I don't
know what that was either we all debated
whether we were going to show you that
thing because it seems to be making its
rounds across the internet of course
that's Mark Zuckerberg and Bill Gates
talking about Harvard they're both
Harvard dropouts and I guess they became
successful and you know world domination
and everything else but what to weirdo
like they don't come off as human they
are humanoid lizard something or other
very uncomfortable I don't like it very
much anyway it's January 3rd 2024 that's
right we are live streaming on Rumble
locals and YouTube uh postgame show
Ruben report. locals.com as always and
uh of course the big news of the day is
that Claude Dean gay has been uh well
she's going to not fired right she's not
officially fired she is uh resigned She
Is Res designed as president of Harvard
although she will stay on in the
political science department which is
just sort of absolutely perfect like oh
you know you're for genocide all the
plagiarism go be a poai professor
that'll be just fine uh but it is a
major win it is a major win against the
woke and Today's show is going to be a
series of wins that we are getting uh
against the woke one of the things we're
going to start with is this absolutely
spectacular video it's from about a week
ago uh during the break so some of you
may have seen it already but Doug Murray
went up against Jen yuger from The Young
Turks on what's going on with Israel and
Hamas and it is one of the most
absolutely beautiful chef's kiss moments
ever in the history of television and
I'm going to dive deep into how when you
get the winds that we are starting to
get when you expose the the frauds and
the grifters and everything else that
you keep pushing you keep pushing you
don't say oh we got a little win let's
go home no you keep pushing uh because
that actually is how we will change
things over the long term so that's the
plan for today and let's just dive right
into it we've got two clips of this uh
Douglas Murray the brilliant Douglas
Murray verse Jank yuger on Israel Hamas
part one I just mentioned about seeing
Wars because as far as I can see you're
very ill traveled as well as rather ill
lettered and Ill spoken and I mention
that I cover Wars and go to Wars because
I happen to think myself that it's worth
seeing things with your own eyes
including things that you don't
particularly like but you report the
truth I don't know if you ever even
leave your own bedroom and I can tell
already that you don't because you've
already said something that demonstrates
you know nothing about this conflict you
have just demonstrated it in the
following terms you said that this is
why we need to push for a two-state
solution and give legitimacy to the
Palestinian Authority I'll tell you
something you don't know because I guess
you spent no time in the West Bank have
you I'll tell you something you probably
don't know the Palestinian Authority fat
celebrated the 7th of October massacres
I'll give you another fact which
demonstrates you know nothing about this
and clearly haven't ever visited any
Palestinians in the West Bank as I have
if there was an election tomorrow in the
West Bank the reason why there isn't one
is because if there was an election
tomorrow in the West Bank Hamas would
win so your idea of a two-state solution
I'm afraid you are so out of date and
you really should leave your bedroom
because in this region nobody thinks
that there is a two-state solution on
the table because there is not a viable
negotiating partner but I just want to
make one other main point you have gone
on and on tonight throwing accusations
out against the Jewish State against me
it's the sort of thing you do I know
you're a sort of sort of online pugilist
and think you can run for office and
good luck with
that I mean there's just nobody better
like Douglas is grade A Perfection at
just
dissecting the truth and and surgically
destroying all of the grifters and Jank
is an absolute grifter of course it
should be noted that I did work for Jank
at The Young Turks years ago and in some
ways I thank him because if it wasn't
for him being such an over-the-top
ridiculous leftist buffoon and a racist
and there's a whole bunch of other stuff
that I could go on and on about and they
talk about me all the time over there
this is only the second or third time I
think I've ever mentioned him on this
show and I'm only doing it to illustrate
Douglas's Brilliance not to go after him
um
it's just perfect what Douglas did there
I want to just reference a couple things
first off the idea of a two-state
solution is complete nonsense and it has
always been complete nonsense of course
the West Bank and Gaza aren't even
connected so you'd have Israel in
between so that would be a three-state
solution Douglas also illustrates the
point that you'd have Hamas running
these states that would be a problem uh
also the Palestinian Authority which is
what uh Jen was calling for to to run
the West Bank and they sort of run the
West Bank right now they literally pay
people to kill Jews that would be uh
problematic but Douglas just kind of
lays it all out perfectly and and the
fact that Jen just sat there and he's
such a bloviating buffoon just sat there
and took it shows you that he really
knew uh he was being eviscerated but
here's part two where it really gets
good but I'd just like to point out that
you only really get animated if the Jews
are involved and I can tell that for the
following reason I mean your surname is
weager isn't it 1 million weager Muslims
in China have been putting concentration
camps in the last decade and PE you know
people of your ilk never really care
about that do you because it's not the
Jews doing it it's a Chinese Communist
party at the moment 1 million P Pak one
million people who are from Pak who are
in Pakistan at the moment who are your
fellow Muslims and who happen to be
Afghan and I don't think you care about
them do you 1 million Afghans are
currently being forcibly deported from
Pakistan to Afghanistan you don't care
about that you're not riled up about
that you're not riled up about what the
jungle weed are currently doing in Sudan
where thousands and thousands of people
are being attacked by the by the the
islamist militia there you don't care
about any of that you get exercised and
you rile up what little base you have of
Mal contents because you're riled up
when the Jews do anything perfectly
obvious okay I don't even need to show
you more than that he then calls Douglas
a racist and that's how it ends because
of course that's all they've got but
this this notion that Douglas is hitting
on this idea that these people and Jen
is a perfect example this they don't
care about the weager genocide in China
they don't care what's happening to
people in Syria they don't care that the
real Palestinians if there were real
Palestinians are actually living under
apartheid in Jordan the hashimite
kingdom of Jordan which doesn't allow
them to have certain jobs and doesn't
allow them to vote and that in Lebanon
there are all sorts of jobs that they
can't have in places that they're not
allowed to live in all of those things
none of those people care about that it
only matters when it's the Jews now I
bring this up because it is deeply
connected to what happened yesterday
with Claude Dean gay resigning as the
president of Harvard the frauds are
being exposed when you put everybody in
that Matrix of Oppression and you say
these people are automatically the bad
guys because of their skin color or
whatever and these people are
automatically the good guys you build up
a world and you build up institutions
like Harvard and so many of our media
institutions that are completely
fraudulent and now finally after all of
these years after all of us talking
about this for so long it has burst
forth in in sort of the most disgusting
way right the last 3 months it's burst
forth because of the horrific medieval
barbarity of Hamas but it's it's sh it's
shined a light on so much of what's
backwards right now and I think good
people are actually starting to get it
so we're going to expand on that in just
a second but let me talk to you about
the satellite phone store guys are you
in the need for a satellite phone you
know they're about to drop some of this
Epstein list and uh you know you never
know what they're going to do once they
do that so you might want want to get
one uh well sat1 123.com has made it
easy for anyone to get one satat phones
are a secure way to communicate with no
tracking and no one can listen to your
calls or read your texts the ersat ISAT
satellite phone is free on a 15-month
agreement limited time only an extra
free battery is also included $95.95 per
month no cost for the phone 100 minutes
or texts are also included family plan
multi free phones are also available an
extra free battery for each phone is
also included these phones will work
from anywhere on Earth cell phones work
on only 7% of the earth if you can see
the sky you will be able to make a call
if the cellular networks go down you'll
still be able to stay in communication
with loved ones but satellite phones
will always work all satellite phone
Communications are encrypted Ure privacy
by using proprietary satellite networks
entrusted by the US government for
decades the US Senate recently issued a
satellite phone for private calls and
security satellite phones can't be
tracked big Tech can't access your data
this year in the US we experienced Maui
cell phone service going down on 90% of
the island 60,000 people stuck in the
desert where only people with sat phones
were able to communicate hurricanes that
took cell service down be prepared be
prepared go to sat12 3.com and get your
family ready Christmas time has just
passed but you can still give a gift in
security and connections there you go
all right so let's connect the
frauds the grifters the Liars the wers
the people who have pushed F racist M on
all of us decided who good guys and bad
guys are based on immutable
characteristics they are being exposed
at accelerating rates uh but let's go
back to what sort of blew this whole
thing up uh you may remember this right
before the break this is the
Congressional hearing uh where Claud
Dean gay president of Harvard could not
figure out whether calling for the
genocide of Jews violated the code of
conduct for the students at Harvard and
Dr Gay at har Harvard does calling for
the genocide of Jews violate Harvard's
rules of bullying and harassment yes or
no it can be depending on the context
what's the context targeted as an
individual targeted as at an individual
it's targeted at Jewish students Jewish
individuals do you understand your
testimony is dehumanizing them do you
understand that dehumanization is part
of
anti-Semitism I will ask you one more
time
does calling for the genocide of Jews
violate Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or
no anti-semitic rhetoric when it
anti-semitic rhetoric anti-semitic
rhetoric when it crosses into conduct
that amounts to bullying harassment
intimidation that is actionable conduct
and we do take action so the answer is
yes that calling for the genocide of
Jews violates Harvard code of conduct
[Music]
correct again it depends on the context
it does not depend on the context the
answer is yes and this is why you should
resign these are unacceptable answers
across the board all right it's worth
noting again and I know you guys know
this because you're wise people who
watch the Ruben report that her uh line
there when she says it crosses into
conduct uh the implication is that you
can say whatever you want but it's not
till you beat the kid or you kill K the
kid or you commit the genocide that
they'll do anything now remember this
had nothing to do with the First
Amendment we can talk about that little
bit of gray area related to calling for
genocide of a group of people that is
protected by the First Amendment there
is some gray area there where they
specifically talking about these people
right in front of you or a group of
people there's something to discuss
there but this hearing was about the
code of conduct the policy that Harvard
has that's not a First Amendment
government policy that is a handbook
that they hand all of the students and
they say hey here are the rules that we
have here at our University related to
how you're going to treat fellow
students so she completely dropped the
ball there of course she wasn't the
other one there were a couple other
college presidents there uh Liz McGill
uh from Penn has already stepped down uh
but she really stepped down for another
reason the reason she stepped down was
because after that hearing uh Chris rufo
from the Manhattan Institute who's been
on the show many times he's a he's a
friend of mine he's a good guy and he
has been one of the main I would say
drivers of destroying the woke
institutions he started doing a little
research got a couple people with him
and they started checking into Claud
Dean gay what's the deal with her and a
whole bunch of plagiarism including
stealing from other black female
academics was exposed and yesterday she
officially resigned we've got some info
here from Abigail Anthony at the
National Review Harvard president
Claudine gay announced her resignation
on Tuesday culminating weeks of mounting
pressure that began after Gay's widely
criticized appearance before Congress
and escalated due to high-profile
reports of plagiarism in the embattled
academics published work gay served as
the Harvard president for 6 months and
two days and her resignation ends the
shortest presidency in the University's
history it has become clear that it is
in the best interest of Harvard for me
to resign so that our community can
navigate this moment of extraordinary
challenge with a focus on the
institution rather than any individual
gay wrote in an email to the Harvard
University Community announcing her
resignation obtained by the National
Review amidst all of this it has been
distressing to have Doubt cast on my
commitments to confronting hate and to
upholding scholarly rigor to bedrock
values that are fundamental to who I am
and frightening to be subjected to
personal attacks and threats fueled by
racial animists gay continued according
to the statement gay will return to her
position on the faculty while President
gay has acknowledged missteps and taken
responsibility for them it is also true
that she has shown remarkable resilience
in the face of deeply personal and
sustained attacks reads an email by the
Harvard Corporation while some of this
has played out in the public domain much
of it has taken the form of repugnant
and in some cases racist vitriol
directed at her through disgraceful
emails and phone calls we condemn such
attacks in the strongest possible terms
the Harvard Corporation released a
statement on December 12th reaffirming
its support for Gay's leadership of the
University
according to the statement the fellows
of Harvard College initiated an
independent review of Gay's published
work at her request and on December 9th
concluded that were there were a few
instances of inadequate citation while
the analysis found no violation of
Harvard's standards for research
misconduct president gay is proactively
requesting four Corrections in two
articles to insert citations and
quotation marks that were omitted from
the original Publications the statement
continues National Review reported that
that the scholars who believe their work
was plagiarized by gay were not
contacted by Harvard during its
investigation Lee jum a social
psychologist and distinguished professor
at Ruckers University told the National
Review he's never seen anything like the
plagiarism Scandal involving gay the
total of unique plagiarism allegations
against gay has risen to nearly 50 the
Washington Free Beacon reported okay so
two things are happening here right on
one hand she won't say whether calling
for the genocide of some of her students
uh is bad or not that's a problem
whether that's a violation of their
policies and then she gets caught in
over 50 counts of plagiarism these are
the same types of counts of plagiarism
that would get any student at Harvard
kicked out now I'm not for anyone
calling up the university and saying
mean things about her or saying anything
racist or anything else but you can see
that the Harvard statement it's trying
to portray she's the real victim here
right she's the Victim Because clearly
they're going after this black woman
Colin Wright who's an author he's been
on the Ruben report a couple times over
the years he tweeted this out I thought
it was quite good prediction Harvard
president Claudine gay will resign but
she will not admit any wrongo wrongdoing
instead she will claim to be the victim
of a racist right-wing Witch Hunt that
is impacting her mental health and
causing for a needless distraction for
students and faculty and you can already
see of course this is exactly what's
happening everyone is saying the
right-wing media the conservatives are
pouncing and this is proof of systemic
racism and they would never treat a
white person like this and everything
else now keep in mind Liz McGill who is
the president of Penn already stepped
down she didn't even have a plagiarism
Scandal right she just stepped down
because her answers at the Congressional
hearing were equally as bad and she's
white so they took out a white woman and
now they're taken out a black woman if
anything you would say oh you've done
more bad stuff claudean gate cuz you've
also got the plagiarism Scandal anyway
let's uh go back about 7 months ago to
when Claudine gay got the gig at Harvard
and here's the mainstream media telling
you how wonderful this woman was and
you're not going to believe why well
she's black Harvard University making it
history by naming its first black
president well for the first time in
history a black woman will lead Harvard
University some more good news here at
Stanford alum and former Professor has
been named Harvard University's first
black president their very first
president of color she will be the first
person of color first president of color
Claudine gay will be the first president
of color and second female president in
the school's history she's also only the
second woman to hold that position she
will be the second woman and the first
black person to lead the university she
was born to Haitian immigrant the
daughter of Haitian immigrants Professor
gay is a widely admired higher educated
higher education leader and recognized
as an highly influential expert on
American political participation Harvard
has always found a way to meet the
moment we have a long history of rising
to meet new challenges of converting
this energy into forces of renewal and
reinvention I'm clapping for her can
anyone remind me what color and gender
she is I can't remember so anyway that's
of course the way it was framed right
that she is black and she is a woman and
son daughter whatever of immigrants
apparently she's also not actually gay
which is hilarious but just remember for
just a second had that Congressional
hearing happened and she was up there
with the president of upen and the
president of MIT had she gone up there
and said you know what actually uh
calling for the genocide of Jewish
students here at Harvard uh that is a
violation of our standards and practices
of our of our policies and we're going
to do more about that this Scandal would
have completely gone away she would have
answered the question properly people
would have been like boy Liz Mcgill and
the MIT lady they really dropped the
ball on this thing uh but that claudian
gay was pretty good she acknowledged
that there is a problem there so this
has nothing to do with a group of people
unjustly going after her because she's
black and a woman it is because of her
faulty uh that's not even really the
right word her really just absolutely
negligent answer uh while she was
testifying and then of course the
plagiarism Scandal so okay so we just
showed you a compilation of what the me
mainstream media was doing when she was
hired in the first place what we are now
going to show you I know I say this
every now and again on the show but this
might be this might be it this might
actually be it this might be the most
insane thing ever uttered on cable news
this is absolutely extraordinary this is
a guy by the name of Matt eeggan on CNN
and he's explaining a bit about her
plagiarism scan
or was it actually plagiarism listen to
Matt these plagiarism allegations uh
where Claud and gay has had to issue
Corrections um multiple Corrections now
we should note that um claudon gay has
not been accused of stealing anyone's
ideas in any of her writings uh she's
been accused of sort of more like
copying uh other people's writings
without attribution so it's been more
sloppy attribution than stealing
anyone's ideas but nonetheless you you
put all of that together I'm sorry we
have to throw back to that one can we
throw back that that is just incredible
she didn't steal ideas she just copied
and pasted can we do it oneism
allegations uh where claudian gay has
had to issue Corrections um multiple
Corrections now multiple we should note
that um claudon gay has not been accused
of stealing anyone's ideas in any that's
what she's accused of U she's been
accused of sort of more like copying
other people's writings without
attribution so it's been more sloppy
attribution that stealing anyone the
stuff the way they carry water for these
people you do not hate journalists
enough you really don't the corporate
press as my friend Michael malice always
says the corporate press is the enemy of
the people that is the most absurd she
didn't steal she just
stole anyway let's go over to the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC uh because of course they're
blaming
I think the gotcha mentality though is
in fact the point let's just be very
clear the testimony from the president
horrific so they they horrific it was
absolutely terrible they answered a
human question with an academic answer
uh that they were prepped by their
universities quite frankly to give so
that's law and law firms terrible staff
work okay across the board but on top of
that what happened in the aftermath of
that particularly as it relates to Dr
Gay uh the calls came and said she was
terrible in this hearing and she's
unqualified in 387 years only two women
have been president of Harvard
University one the first woman was
before Claud and gay only one black
woman has been president and that black
woman now six months after uh has
resigned from her job because in look at
the statement it's in the best interest
of Harvard to resign so the community
can navigate with focus on the
institution rather than an individual
Harvard decided that it was WEA to un
unable to continue to weather the storm
and while I don't think the culture wars
frankly that play out on campuses across
the country will eventually have a the
biggest effect in general come 2024 what
will have an effect as to Doug said is
how Jewish students feel on college
campuses how Arab American students feel
on college campuses and how every black
professional in America can turn on
their television today see this news
about Dr Claud and gay and and all have
the same reaction m it looks it it it
looks as though she was targeted it's
interesting stuff you use your own you
said she was horrific and then we had a
series of scandals she's she then
targeted herself again she was worse
than fighters in testifying before
Congress that's a low bar I guess I will
just say this is that you know again 387
years I much like when we talked about
classified documents with former
presidents and vice presidents and I
have said you know there's no protocol
in which to pack up a president or vice
president Le's office and I think if you
go to any home of a former president
vice president you might accidentally
find a classified document or two not
necessarily nuclear secrets but you know
maybe a piece of paper that they
shouldn't have took out same thing look
at all what other presidents of Harvard
have been investigated for plagiarism
and if we want to be very specific which
I think we should they the the issues of
plagiarism it is loose citations again
not something I would want I would want
to do but I'm just all I'm
saying old
fashioned there's so much there it's
like what do what do we even do with
this but it's it's not plagiarism guys
it's loose citations they rewrite
history right in front of us in real
time it's extraordinary imagine if a kid
at Harvard it doesn't even matter what
discipline they were in hands in a paper
and there's a whole bunch of stuff that
they just copied and pasted they didn't
play DW it they just copied and pasted
they borrowed ideas they Loosely this
and that you would be kicked out of
school so she's just resigning and now
will be a professor of political science
of course of course political science uh
there's a whole bunch other stuff there
I don't know exactly what uh Simone
Sanders was trying to say about how
Jewish and Arab students are now going
to feel on those campuses but the idea
that somehow again they're going after
her because she's black I have no
problem if you if somebody out there if
Simone or any of you people who are
always trying to tell us all how racist
we are why don't you guys do some
digging and every white College
president who has done the level of
plagiarism that uh Claudine gay has is
done should step down or should at least
be exposed and then the school can
decide what to do right like of course
this has nothing to do with racism and
again Liz McGill you pen she already
stepped down but what did I say was the
the theme of the show today the theme of
the show is that when you get these wins
right when you blow up an absolute fraud
and grifter like Jen yug as Douglas
Murray did or you get a win by having
the
plagiarist let's say at least somewhat
racist or just deeply stupid because of
intersectionality Claud and gay have to
resign when you get some of these wins
you got to keep going right there's an
inclination to just take your foot off
the pedal and be like oh we got a couple
wins you want to have lunch but you got
to keep going because we actually are in
a culture War right now so uh
representative New York representative
Alise stepanic who is the one that was
doing the questioning during that
Congressional hearing uh she was on Fox
yesterday talking about how they are not
going to stop pushing on this stuff this
Congressional investigation is not going
to stop because of the resignation of
these University presidents there are
deep institutional rots in these
formerly prestigious universities
whether it's their Dei offices or
whether it's the anti-Semitism that we
see raging on college campuses so I
think the investigation is going to
uncover much much more this is just you
know about the University president on
top of the institution but it's an
Institutional rout that we are
addressing because these colleges get
billions of taxpayer dollars and I
believe as we continue our Congressional
investigation that we will uncover what
will be the greatest scandal in higher
education because the Harvard
Corporation members themselves are
complicit in this cover up of her
plagiarism and again most importantly
their failure to protect Jewish students
on campus all right that's the right
Spirit again you get a win and now you
keep going what's really going on at
Harvard how much discrimination against
Jewish students Asian students white
students have they been doing over the
years did they get a whole bunch of
professors who were not qualified who
were plagiarizing and a whole bunch more
who had all sorts of awful ideas related
to Marxism and communism and wokeism and
everything else did they all rise up the
ranks while they took good professors
out did all of those things happen
probably I'd like to show you another
clip of fox they had a really fantastic
guest on yesterday this guy Dave Rubin
he was on to discussed this and I
thought he made a really good point
let's watch you know she alleges that
that her mistakes the plagarism
accusations were all corrected but the
Harvard honor Council which is a student
group says that students are not allowed
to correct mistakes without penalties so
why should she be allowed to all of a
sudden just go on after saying well we
fixed all those accusations yeah well
Trace let me answer your previous
question very clearly this is because of
the plagiarism thing not the
anti-semitism these schools and schools
that have allowed Dei to enter and put
everybody in this insane Matrix of
Oppression where again Jews and white
people are sort of at the top of it and
black and brown students are at the
bottom thus they are the oppressed and
can say anything that they want about
the perceived oppressors that's not what
got her fired what got her fired is that
they now have all of these instances of
plagiarism and the Very students who
would be kicked out of school or at
least kicked out of certain programs for
doing just this even this is too blatant
right in their faces so that's really
why she's getting fired here there's
always pressure to Bear but as you noted
the board had already backed her when it
came to that it's only since the
instances of plagiarism have come out
that they finally did the right thing
but again I think it's worth mentioning
you know the question always with these
with these people is okay who's going to
replace them and is there any evidence
that Harvard will suddenly get someone
in charge that will be based in
meritocracy and competence and anything
else or have they already gone so down
that Rabbit Hole of Dei and wokeness
that they'll bring in someone worse
that's generally how they do we got to
play more clips of that guy I mean it's
nice when you get somebody on cable news
who knows what they's doing uh look the
point there is I think the the latter
point that I was trying to make that and
this is what happens with everything
right when you are part of this woke
thing uh when you are a Democrat
politician what do I always say like the
only privilege in America is Democrat
privilege you fall up right you fail up
so you destroy San Francisco if you're
Gavin Newsome you become the governor of
California like all of these things you
know you're you're Brian stelter on CNN
your show gets cancelled because you're
awful you become a professor at Harvard
you're Lori Lightfoot mayor of Chicago
you destroy the city of Chicago you
become a professor at Harvard it's
interesting that Harvard seems to be the
epicenter of so much of this so I have
no great uh I have no Grand Illusions
here that suddenly Harvard is going to
bring in somebody who's going to fix all
this as stepanic is pointing out the rot
is so deep the inst institutional rot
there is so deep over so many decades
right they took over the institutions
they have instituted all of these
backwards crazy racist ideas they have
taught children what to think young
people I should say they've taught young
people what to think instead of how to
think and can any of it be saved I have
no idea if anyia could be saved but I do
want to mention one other thing which is
that again I just want to reiterate she
is not being fired because of the
anti-Semitism thing Liz McGill was right
they just they were like all right we'll
take her out Claudine could have skated
by by being a black woman like it would
have been enough to get her through the
anti-Semitism thing because of that
oppression of uh Olympics that these
people view everything through it's only
because of the plagiarism thing the the
black woman thing that card would have
got her out of it uh anyway as this
fight has raged on we're seeing a real
disconnect right now between the way
that the mainstream media is covering
this which is mostly that she's a black
woman and she's been fired and that
proves that white supremacy is on the
March versus what's happening online
where I think people are trying to
analyze this barely honestly for the
most part at least that's what I'm
trying to do over here and people are
picking up on that so Colin Wright who I
referenced earlier he had a good tweet
on this he wrote pre Elon Musk Twitter
would have never allowed the Claud gay
Scandal to get off the ground they would
have gone on a Banning deboosting and
visibility filtering spree it would have
not been allowed to Trend look what we
can achieve when we are at muzzled and
Elon Musk responded yep so this again
it's one of those stories that proves
the importance of free speech and
relating this to yesterday's show where
Sam Harris was talking to uh Jordan
Peterson and basically saying you know
Elon is just addicted to Twitter and he
got he bought Twitter for the $47
million just because he wants his ego
stroked and it's like actually look what
just happened because Elon got Twitter
we've started to expose some of the
institutional rot and they're absolutely
there's just no doubt that Colin is
correct on that right like had the old
regime at Twitter been in place we have
no idea what the layers of censorship
are the Deb boosting visibility
filtering that's what they say meaning
you're following somebody but you just
don't see their tweets we don't know
whether the government might have gotten
involved in silen people and a whole
bunch more so the point is right now we
actually have some I would say some
between Twitter and Rumble locals Etc we
have some of the tools to win and take
these people out so we can not
stop and speaking of a guy who does not
stop my friend Russell Brand had a nice
little uh a little uh di tribe a little
diddly let's say on uh how the truth is
concealed and that you don't need Grand
conspiracies to pull things off the
truth is often concealed and manipulated
when various interests appear to
conspire to manage information in ways
that seem advantageous to the interests
of the powerful remember you have to be
careful about using the word conspiracy
because as George Harin always said
where interests converge no conspiracy
is necessary these people went to the
same universities and fraternities they
on the same Boards of directors they're
on the same country clubs they have like
interests they don't need to call a
meeting they know what's good for them
that we should play more George Carl and
stuff so yes you don't need a grand
conspiracy when you when you look around
at the world right now and you go how is
all of this crazy stuff possible how is
it that we now make it so that if you're
not racist you're actually RAC and how
is it that if you have a penis we call
you a girl and a whole bunch of other
stuff and it's like well there has been
not a grand conspiracy per se but a
series of people who have attained power
by going through these institutions and
they don't have to have a secret closed
door meeting to pull off all of the bad
ideas right you don't have to have Mark
Zuckerberg and Bill Gates like get a
group in a scary Castle somewhere in
Transylvania to sit around a table like
when they have like the the evil
Republican meetings in The Simpsons back
in the day you don't really need that
you just need a whole bunch of people
that have run through the same
institutions that kind of think the same
things and play golf together and go to
the same restaurants and country clubs
and their lives are basically the same
and then it's not exactly a conspiracy
when they're pushing all of this crap on
you right and they never want their
children to be learning any of this
stuff of course they want public
education to teach this crap while they
have their children in little pods and
private schools and charter schools and
all of those other things but the point
again guys is that if we don't stop if
we keep going when we have a win then we
will actually start seeing some results
and the results are actually happening
right now check this out this is from
Abigail Anthony at the National Review
the early action applications for
Harvard this cycle dropped by 177% from
9553 in 2022 to
7,921 in 2023 so that means and this is
great news that parents I think it's
mostly parents in this case but maybe
some of the kids too are going you know
what maybe I don't need to get into all
of that debt to go to Harvard maybe
there's a young Asian kid out there
who's like you know what it was the
dream it was my dream it was the dream
of my parents and everybody else to get
into Harvard but turns out that that
place discriminates against me and even
though I do have better grades than the
people they're letting in maybe I don't
need to walk out of that place with a C
happy education where I'm going to be
discriminated against not treated well
also not really learn much of anything
and then I'll be discriminated against
also when I get into the workforce
because I'm Asian maybe I should just
extrapolate myself from that get out of
that system and go somewhere else so
that's happening to Harvard right now
but I want to continue with this theme
that we cannot stop and you know why we
can't stop because I just Illustrated
how we're we're winning because of
what's happening on Twitter so we can
expose some of this stuff right Chris
rufo actually all of the docu doents
that were exposed about Claud Dean gay
and you can actually see the copy paste
jobs that she did this was all Exposed
on Twitter so what is the machine going
to do well it's going to keep pushing
for censorship let's go up to New York
and Kathy hokel governor of New York uh
she's moving on more social media
censorship we also talked about I
mentioned social media number of times
I've called upon and working closely
with our attorney general to identify
what's going on on social media those
questions are now part of our background
checks just like in the old days you
talk to someone's neighbor uh now you
can talk to their neighbors online and
find out whether or not this person has
been spouting uh you philosophies that
indicate that they have been radicalized
and that's how we protect our citizens
oh philosophy is whether they've been
radicalized but what will that actually
mean and once the government starts
doing that is not is that not an
infringement on your first amendment and
what are radical views is it a radical
view to say that we should not be racist
we should be colorblind that we should
judge people by the content of their
character not the color of their skin or
I don't know depends what she thinks I
suppose and that is the problem and
that's why they are constantly trying to
censor Twitter and they are trying to
censor you and everything else so again
we keep pushing and keep pushing and
keep pushing and then there's another
piece of it that will wrap this show
with a nice little bow the other piece
is that when you push and push and push
and you get wins you also have to make
some decisions for yourself you have to
look around you and go do I live in a
community that is like-minded enough to
feel like my family can flourish here
can I accomplish the things that I want
to accomplish do I live in a place that
has I don't know clean streets and
doesn't have drug addicts all over the
place and homeless people everywhere can
I open up a store if that's what I want
to do or do I feel safe going to work
all of those things are my kids Gonna
Learn decent things at school and you
might look around if many of you are
watching this in blue States or blue
cities right now you might be looking
around going man that that's not really
working out and you know what you can do
you can pick up you can pick up your
life and you can move somewhere else
that is the beauty of the United States
it is the beauty of federalism what a
brilliant brilliant idea our Founders
had with the Federalist Papers that the
states were going to mostly be in charge
so that laboratory as Dennis Prager
calls it would constantly be going oh
that laws over there and that State this
laws over here in this state that state
taxes you high this state taxes you low
you could figure out where you want to
move as opposed to having to leave the
country which is what you have to do in
most other countries I relate all of
this because last night on Fox News Shan
Hannity BN and bred in New York City
born in New York City has lived in Long
Island for I think about four decades he
is officially leaving New York moving to
the free state of Florida in fact
tonight we are now broadcasting from my
new home the great free state of Florida
like so many Americans I left New York
for good and am now in the state with
let's see warmer weather Law and Order
better education more freedom uh better
quality of life and guess what no state
income
tax ain't rocket science it ain't rocket
science I just have no doubt let let's
reach out to Sean we should do something
live here in Florida with him and just
talk about that he just had it like
think about it Sean hady the guy is
probably worth 50 million bucks like
this isn't money you know he says the
tax thing at the end but it wasn't about
taxes that got him there right like all
his roots are in New York as I said born
in New York City um but he looked around
he was doing his show every day from
that office in in Midtown and looking
around going boy this ain't New York
City that it used to be doesn't really
feel safe here there are mobs calling
for genocide that's a problem when I'm
on my way to work I think I'm going to
move to the pre State of Florida anyway
it might make you think about something
as we roll into the beginning beginning
of the year guys people of the internet
is live at 1 p.m and if you want to join
us for the postgame show right now Ruben
report. locals.com and we did not
mention the elderly man running for
president during the show today so we
leave you with a cold close of Joseph R
Biden
enjoy and action well every morning well
let me put this way at least four
mornings a week sorry cut we have to cut
I've written extensively as a what when
I was a law professor okay you know what
no cut our in our our Administration the
financial collapse the jobs they lost
and how they never got back to where
they needed to be okay are you kidding
me we organized the
world um but uh um you know uh uh what's
go what look the only thing I know
something about is the vice presidency
come on cut this noise is I think
over 30 or 40 million people this this
is instead of having in the in
minority communities I'm making the
number up things that are out there that
that people I'm sorry didn't turn
[Music]
off